- Une foule immense qui a envahi
le tarmac pour tenter de fuir
par tous les moyens
l'Afghanistan.
(coups de feu, cris)
- Kaboul, 26 août 2021.
- Le Canada a mis fin à
son opération d'évacuation.
- Dans le chaos le plus total,
les militaires canadiens
quittent l'Afghanistan après
avoir extirpé 3700 personnes
de cet enfer. Mais la mission
se termine avec un goût amer.
- Évidemment, c'est frustrant.
- Moi, je trouve ça
inacceptable.
- Car beaucoup d'Afghans,
en danger de mort, ont été
laissés derrière.
(klaxons)
♪ ♪ ♪
Cela fait maintenant 2 mois que
l'Afghanistan est entièrement
aux mains des talibans.
(klaxons)
Deux mois de clandestinité,
de stress et de terreur pour des
milliers d'anciens interprètes
et employés locaux de l'armée
canadienne et leur entourage,
coincés en Afghanistan.
Nous en avons retracé
une demi-douzaine.
Ils vivent tous aujourd'hui
cachés et dans la peur
d'être découverts.
Leur visage a été masqué
pour protéger leur identité.
Tareen a travaillé deux ans
comme interprète pour
les forces canadiennes; employé
entre autres par l'équipe
provinciale de reconstruction.
Mais cet été, il a dû fuir
Kandahar pour se réfugier
à Kaboul.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les talibans ont détruit
sa maison et menacé ses voisins.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est aussi à Kaboul que
se cache Matiullah, terrorisé.
Il a travaillé trois ans avec
les Canadiens comme pharmacien
et technicien médical à
l'hôpital militaire de Kandahar.
Avec eux, il a contribué
à sauver des vies.
Et le danger est encore
plus élevé à Kandahar,
où Naveed est resté.
Ses années de service auprès
des forces spéciales canadiennes
ne lui procurent aucune
protection. Bien au contraire.
- C'est clair, je suis fâché
avec qu'est-ce qui se passe
là-bas parce que c'est
inacceptable.
- Cela fait déjà plusieurs
années que le réserviste
David Morrow a raccroché
son uniforme. Il a été
l'un des derniers Canadiens
déployés à Kandahar en 2011.
Mais l'Afghanistan ne l'a
jamais vraiment quitté.
- J'ai jamais vraiment parti
complètement de l'Afghanistan
parce que j'avais toujours
un lien avec mon interprète.
- David est aujourd'hui dégoûté
en constatant le manque
d'empressement du Canada
à sauver ses anciens
interprètes afghans.
- Moi, j'étais fier d'être
soldat canadien. Mais depuis,
je dirais, juin, juillet,
puis la réponse du gouvernement
canadien, j'ai pas cette
fierté-là. Ça a parti.
- Avec d'autres anciens
combattants canadiens, il a
dressé une liste de 10 000
personnes à sauver d'urgence.
Une liste transmise
à Immigration Canada.
Mais depuis, il déplore
le peu de résultats.
- Sur cette liste-là, nous avons
seulement 8 % de ces noms-là qui
sont arrivés ici au Canada.
Clairement, c'est un échec.
- Ce n'est qu'en juillet
dernier, plus de 10 ans
après avoir quitté Kandahar,
que le Canada a mis en place
un plan pour protéger
ses anciens interprètes.
Un programme créé en urgence
sous la pression des anciens
combattants, indignés.
Parmi eux, le major-général
Denis Thompson, qui commandait
en 2008-2009 le détachement
canadien en Afghanistan.
- Je ne sais pas si je suis
fâché ou déçu, mais je suis
frustré, ça, c'est vrai.
Ces gens, ils méritent
notre attention.
- Constatant l'inaction
d'Ottawa, les anciens
combattants ont mis
sur pied une ONG pour aider
eux-mêmes les Afghans menacés.
Le tout géré à distance
avec très peu de moyens.
- C'est quand même un devoir
moral, c'est pas le moment de
laisser tomber nos camarades
d'armes.
(sonnerie de téléphone)
- L'implication d'Ottawa
se limite au traitement
par Immigration Canada des
dossiers de ceux qui ont réussi
à quitter le pays par eux-mêmes.
- Vous avez joint la ligne
téléphonique dédiée aux mesures
spéciales d'immigration
au Canada pour les Afghans.
- Une lourdeur administrative
dénoncée de tous côtés.
- Ça semble qu'il n'y a
aucune urgence. Ça semble
qu'ils travaillent juste
comme status quo.
- Sollicité pour une entrevue,
le ministre canadien
de l'Immigration a refusé
de répondre à nos questions.
- Il faut trouver une autre
solution pour évacuer
ce monde-là.
- Comme beaucoup d'anciens
combattants, le général Thompson
souhaite un sérieux coup de
barre d'Ottawa dans ce dossier.
- Mais il faut plus d'action,
sur le terrain, physiquement,
pour que ce monde puisse quitter
le pays d'Afghanistan.
- Un changement d'attitude
qui doit venir de tout
en haut de la hiérarchie.
Les interprètes afghans
l'ont bien compris.
Mais pour bon nombre d'Afghans,
la confiance est rompue,
l'espoir a disparu. C'est ainsi
en Écosse, qu'Abdul, l'ancien
interprète de David Morrow,
a finalement trouvé refuge.
Après avoir compris, la mort
dans l'âme, qu'il ne pouvait
plus compter sur le Canada.